[Subtitles by Camilla Kristensen]
Moderator (M): "Andy, we're gonna start with
you"
Andy Serkis (AS): "Oh my god"
M: "If that's alright?
You've been involved in both sides of this,
of course this whole journey of being behind
the camera and in front of it.
What are you gonna take away from this experience
and from being able to do both sides of those
things?"
AS: "I'm...
It really is... it's very much...
this whole journey for me it's... extraord...
been extraordinary... both as a... working
on a new technology.
Again, this kind of goes back to where Pete
comes from, as a film maker, and his desire
to push the envelope, and to turn, you know,
reach a point in filmmaking where visual effects
suddenly becomes character, so the whole performance
capture journey's been extraordinary from
that point of view, but then also to be asked
to direct the second unit was an enormous
shock but... it really speaks to Pete's understanding
of... and the way that he collaborates with
all of the cast members and all of the crew,
and as a natural leader and as a brilliant
film maker he's, in terms of being, you know,
without overselling him, 'cause he doesn't
need selling really, but he is... his virtues
are that he is the most incredibly generous
human being, and I think to learn from a director,
who is an incredibly generous human being,
you couldn't ever want a better mentor/teacher"
Peter Jackson (PJ): "I think I'm gonna have
to hire you again then"
AS: "It's a deal"
M: "Lee.
You kind of steal the show with your horseback
entry and this sort of thing..."
Evangeline Lilly (EL): "Elkback"
M: "Sorry elkback, yeah.
It kind of adds to his whole kind of presence
and grandeur doesn't it?
Is it fun to kind of play with?
To kind of even... make him even more kind
of powerful and grandiose?
Lee Pace (LP): "Oh I mean on set that is basically:
"okay, put on this blond wig, put on this
silver armor, and you're gonna sit here",
and I'm like: "what's next" and he goes, "you're
gonna ride an elk into a battle of five armies;
there'll be orks here and...", and you kind
of just go for it, swing your sword around.
And then... and then... and then show up last
night and watch the movie back, and it's just
extraordinary.
This battle is just massive and somehow I
find myself in it"
M: "Orlando"
Orlando Bloom (OB): "Yeah"
M: "How are you sir?"
OB: "Hello love, how are you?"
M: "This must have been an emotional journey
for you.
From being, you know from being there across
the kind of two epics"
OB: "Yeah, yeah it is.
It's been a crazy... crazy to think that I
was 21 when I got casted and moved out to
New Zealand, and I'm 37 now, so puts it slightly
in perspective, but yeah...
It is, it's bitter sweet, it's... there's...
I hope Pete feels a huge sense of achievement
at this point, 'cause I'm feeling a little
bit of that and very grateful to just have
been on the ride really"
M: "Evangeline.
What a character.
She has no fear; she fears nothing.
Would you agree?"
EL: "I totally disagree.
I think that she's terrified of everything
and that she overcomes those fears, and does
it anyway"
M: "She hides it brilliantly"
EL: "Oh great"
M: "You hide it brilliantly"
EL: "That's what elves are supposed to do.
You don't show anything on the outside, it's
all inside"
M: "Richard.
What a journey he goes on in this film.
Was that great to be able to take and to kind
of those depths"
Richard Armitage (RA): "Yeah, I'm trying to
go through this press tour without repeating
the word 'journey' or 'story arc', but really,
Thorin has such an interesting story arc to
play over three movies, and when does one
ever get the opportunity to play a single
story through three pieces, and you know the
material is incredible, Tolkein is incredible,
and the screenplay is absolutely fantastic.
I was given some amazing dialog to say, which
I'm very very grateful for"
Philippa Boyens (PB): "Good answer Richard"
M: "Peter.
Sir, you said that you have a responsibility
with these films, and these characters I guess
as well.
How do you look at that responsibility now
that it's kind of finished and you've delivered
these stories?"
PJ: "I don't have the responsibility any more.
I can go to the beach"
EL: "As you can tell, he does that a lot"
PJ: "But I mean, any filmmmaker's responsibility
because you are spending, you know, you're
spending money that is not yours, and you
know, so you've got to be responsible for
that.
You've...
I mean, I also feel very responsible for the
fact that you're trying to entertain people,
and for me utter failure, is to make a film
that people go to, and they pay the money
to go see it, and they don't like it, and
so, you know, from that point of view, I'm
sure there are people that have seen these
films and they don't like them, but the majority
of people, certainly from what we can see,
the majority of people have gone and enjoyed
them which is, for me, that's why we do what
we do, isn't it?
To give people a good time at the movies.
So yeah..."
M: "Martin.
Hello"
Martin Freeman (MF): "What?!
Christ!"
M: "So rude"
MF: "On and on and on"
M: "I've gotta get down the line and speed
it up a bit.
Not many times an actor gets the chance to
revisit a character on more than one occasion..."
MF: "Yes"
M: "What does it allow you to do then as an
actor?
Does it kind of allow you more freedom or
is it an easier or harder opportunity as an
actor?
MF: "Well ehm, it gives you to opportunity
to actually grow and expand inside what you
are doing, so I love to expand inside of Bilbo
over a course of three years...
What?!...
And ehm...
That's the truth, and I'm only telling the
truth and now I'm being persecuted for it,
and I think we know another man that happened
to, don't we?
No but we...
we"
Ian McKellen (IM): "Jesus Christ!"
M: "This is not the time or the place"
MF: "No I'm just saying, but within that...
yeah we all have...
A long time...
I was gonna be so good on this.
Yeah we have a long time to play and discover
things our characters do, we don't just have
five minutes, you have a long time to sort
of play this, and if it's not your time to...
'cause I was always having the conversation
with Peter, when do I get to be angry, you
know, when do I get to sort of show that different
side, and he would always be saying: "it's
coming, it's coming, don't worry, pace yourself"
you know"
MF: "Exactly, you have to shape it out.
What you learn is to pace yourself, and you
learn to... yeah you learn patience basically,
so that time we want to play that and you
want to show that about that character, it
will come, but you just have to wait, and
it's yeah... it's... yes"
M: "Thank you.
Sir Ian McKellen"
OJ: "Very good... very good answer"
MF: "Thanks very much"
PJ: "No I thought...
I quite enjoyed it"
MF: "Thank you"
M: "Are you finished Martin?"
MF: "Yep"
M: "Sir Ian McKellen.
Do you think you'll ever say goodbye, farewell
to Gandalf?"
PB: "Do you think you'll ever say goodbye
M: "Do you want me to...
I'll shout"
IM: "Oh you see, the thing is, no....
I said goodbye to Gandalf in 2000 when I left
New Zealand.
Well here we are, 2014, it goes on and on
and on, but... and now... and has been the
blessing of my professional life.
I'm...
Like all the other actors we think we are
so bloody lucky.
There's nothing about luck in the making of
the films, of cause that's the planning.
The chance that we were selected...
well... wonderfully...
wonderful.
But I was just impressed last night by the
age of the kids who'd slept out all night
to come and wish us well.
And some of them were born in the last century
when we started...
not born, so our work is part of their lives,
and you know, what are we doing it for other
than to have an effect.
And the effect could be that crucial to them,
and they're now gonna show the films to their
own kids.
To have been involved in films that are now
classics is overwhelming, you can't take any
credit for it, it just happened.
So in the end...
it's not the end, it's the beginning now,
of people seeing the film, and then we'd want
to see the six of them and that would be a
whole other new experience, none of us has
been able to have, until this last Hobbit
was made"
M: "Thank you"
PJ: "24 hours of joy.
We are... just to expand slightly on something
Ian was saying.
I was just thinking last night that we're
about 3 or 4 years away from the generation
that will see these films, the six movies,
in the order that they should see them in;
the story order rather than the order they
were shot.
'Cause you know children that are too young
now, like 3 years old, 4 years old, 5 years
old, are too young to see these films, in
a few years, a very short time, they will
be able to see them, and hopefully they will
see them from the Hobbit 1 through to the
Return of the King, so we're very soon, we're
not gonna have this sort of back-to-front
thing, it'll be like... it will exist as a...
as the six film, you know, story that it should
be so... yeah..."
M: "Was that what you planned from the start?"
PJ: "Well not in The Lord of the Rings, I
didn't know I was gonna do The Hobbit, but
when we knew we were gonna do The Hobbit,
we were always thinking of the full arc of
the story, 'cause there's a lot of stuff in
The Hobbit that we did... that we planted
which is designed to, you know, for people
that do finally see it in the correct order,
it'll make sense"
M: "Can I bring in Philippa, on the other
side of Sir Ian.
Hi Philippa"
PB: "Hi"
M: "I mean, all the foundations we hear in
terms of, you know, you kind of with the films
that has gone before this, but does that make
it easier in terms of kind of knowing where
the end point is, for you in terms of this
final film?"
PB: "Having done The Lord of the Rings first
you mean?"
M: "Yeah"
PB: "Definitely.
I think it was luck that we actually did,
I think, those films first because I think
we would have made a very different Hobbit
if we'd started with The Hobbit, probably
more a children's tale, uhm, and uhm, and
you know, not so say that that's would have
been necessarily a bad thing, but we always
knew, as Peter said, that these was gonna
set against a backdrop of films that were
already in existence, and what I do love now
is that we've seen, for example, the relationship
of Gandalf and Galadriel and that she comes
to save him and... so when she is told in
Fellowship of the Ring that he has died, it's
gonna play in a completely different way.
So that's the experience that I think is gonna
be special for those people who couldn't see
it in that order"
M: "Thank you.
Luke"
Luke Evans (LE): "Hey ya"
M: "Bard the bowman..."
LE: "Bard the lonely bowman"
M: "Everyone needs a bowman to save them.
Was it fun playing the hero?"
LE: "Haha, eh yeah.
He didn't.... he wasn't a hero when I first
read him on the page, he was just the lonely
bargeman.
I know what he was capable of and what he
ends up doing in the third movie, but when
I started playing him, all those years ago,
he was a father of three without a wife and,
you know, he had a long, long journey ahead
of him, but it was very satisfying last night
to actually see the final... the look of that
rooftop sequence which was the first thing
I ever shot, wasn't it Pete?"
PJ: "Yes it was"
LE: "Yeah.
He put me of wires and sent me up a rooftop
for four days"
PJ: "There's a lot of scenes in this movie,
this Battle of the Five armies, that was shot
four years ago, which is a very strange performance"
LE: "That was my... that was four years ago,
I must have shot that, yeah, so I waited a
long time to see that scene"
PJ: "That was something of a bell wasn't it?"
LE: "It was a very big bell yeah"
M: "Ryan, what a great character you have
in Alfrid"
Ryan: "Thank you"
M: "He really helps to set the tone, I think
as well throughout the films, in terms of..."
Someone: "lowers"
Ryan Gage (RG): "He lowers the tone"
M: "He does yeah, I wasn't gonna say that
but ehm... but in terms of... did you really
enjoy kind of...
I guess kind of bringing him into life.
Did you get to play with kind of how...
how... where you took him I guess, in terms
of how that character..."
RG: "Yeah, I mean it was very clear on the
page that he sort of jumps off the page to
me, from the first reading of it but ehm...
yeah we got to play around...
I mean it was a good opportunity for Pete
to be... to play with me and bully me a bit
and throw eggs at me.
So there was great fun to be had, with him
because he has a sort of foolish nature, he's
a sort of dark clownish character, so I enjoyed
being able to find a little bit of me that's
a fool and a bit of me that is vain"
PJ: "There's quite a lot in there actually"
RG: "Thank you.
And a bit of me that is sort of bitter and
greedy and all those things and exaggerate
it, and have fun being that person for a while,
so it was a great treat to be him"
M: "Thank you.
Finally Billy, hello sir, at the end"
Billy Boyd (BB): "Hello"
M: "What a fitting end to this wonderful journey,
with this song: 'The Last Goodbye'.
How did that come about?"
BB: "Uhm, I suppose ehm...
I don't know... no really...
I just know that I liked when I got the phonecall
and I got the chance to go back to New Zealand,
and to work with Fran and Philippa so closely
on writing the song.
Yeah, it's sort of organically happened is
suppose 'cause the song from 'Return of the
King' was in the trailer, and then we started
talking about doing this song, and it sort
of just sort of snowballed from there you
know"
PJ: "But it was...
I mean it was, apart from, you know, the fact
that you've got a fantastic voice, you know,
we...
It was also...
We felt just as an emotional thing, it was
almost like a handover from the first three
films to the second set of three films"
BB: "Yeah"
PJ: "That Pippin sort of jumps in there to...
you know... the beginning of his story I think
is..."
Billy: "I was just thinking about that when
you were talking watching it in the right
order you know so..."
PJ: "Yeah yeah yeah"
BB: "But it was great.
It was so good to be down there, you know,
in a different way when you are used to being
an actor and you leave it to be there at the
this sort of last couple of weeks, and the
excitement of putting it all together, you
know, and getting to sit with Pete as he edited.
That was, you know, a real, real treat; it
was great"
M: "Thank you.
And the gentleman over here, we'll start with
you"
Audience Member: "Thank you very much.
Hello, I'm Marcus from Germany.
This is a question for Peter Jackson, of cause,
next year we get the Blu-ray and DVD of 'The
Hobbit 3', but what happens after this?
Is this really the end of Middle Earth, or
do you see something in the books of Tolkien's
where you would say that it's worth to do
another movie?
I mean, we are in the century of franchise"
PJ: "Erm... we have the extended cut of 'The
Battle of the Five Armies' which is gonna
be a fantastic extended cut, there's some
really great stuff.
I go back to New Zealand in the new year and
we work for four to five months putting that
together, which will be fun, 'cause it's all
gonna be... there's actually some quite good
stuff in it.
So I'm looking forward to that, then no.
Look at that point, I mean it's a legal thing
the Tolkien Estate owns the writings of Professor
Tolkien.
The Hobbit and The Lord of the Rings were
sold by Professor Tolkien in the late sixties,
the film rights, but they are the only two
works of his that have ever been sold as,
you know, potential films so...
So without the corporation of the Tolkien
Estate there can't be any more films.
So yeah..."
M: "Gentleman in the red t-shirt there"
Audience Member: "Another question for Mr.
Jackson.
I was disappointed that I've not yet, I'm
over here"
Peter: "Ah thank you.
Hello"
Audience Member: "Hello.
I'm disappointed that I've not yet had a chance
to see this in 48 frames, but I'm looking
forward to that.
How do you feel now about the whole high frame
rate, I mean I don't know if you call that
an experiment, do you think you continue working
in that format?"
Peter: "Yeah, I mean I just... look I just
think it's a much better way to see films
and I... it's, you know, after the first Hobbit
movie I went back in to the grading room and
I figured out a lot of little tricks to make
it look less like the video thing.
I know that people criticized it the first
time round and I should have understood why
when I... so then I did a lot of work so the
second and third Hobbit movies has got a slightly
different look, a more of a textured look
which I regret I didn't do in the first film,
but it took a while to figure out.
Look...
I... the way I always answer that question,
'cause it's a very fair question, is that
to say that a hundred years ago, movies were
black and white, they were silent, they were
16 frames a second okay?
So a hundred years from now what are they
gonna be?
I mean...
I don't know.
We just do not know what form films are gonna
be in a hundred years time.
But I think that you can absolutely guarantee,
they're not gonna be 24 frames a second, they're
not gonna be 2D so... at what point between
now and a hundred years do these advances
actually happen?
So just think it's... and ultimately, the
audiences for movies are beginning to dwindle
is so much competition for seeing things on
iPhones and iPads and everything else that
it has become a very serious issue for the
industry, 'cause the, you know, the industry
has to have the audiences in order to makes
these films... to feed itself.
So it has become a very serious thing for
the industry of how do you get people to leave
their houses and go to the theater, I mean,
the audiences are slipping away.
So I think it's important that filmmakers
do look at the technology that's available
and just think of how we can use it to make
that experience in the cinema a little bit
more exiting.
So that's my theory."
M: "Thank you.
Lady just here"
Audience Member: "Hi, good afternoon.
This is Tina from Singapore.
I would like to ask the actors and the directors,
this has to be a journey of self-discovery,
so for yourself what have you discovered for
yourself as a person or as an actor through
this journey?"
M: "Who's that to sorry?"
Audience Member: "Sorry?"
M: "Who's that to?
Who would you like to..."
Audience Member: "Just whoever that wishes
to answer"
M: "Who would like to answer that one?"
PJ: "Self-discovery, who..."
M: "Self-discovery.
Martin"
PJ: "I was gonna...
I thought that you would be the best person"
MF: "Oh really?"
PJ: "Yeah"
MF: "It's interesting..."
M: "Martin"
MF: "Oh really?"
M: "Yeah go Martin"
MF: "I didn't find it really one of self-discovery
particularly.
I thoroughly, thoroughly enjoyed it and I
think that's kind of its own worth in a way,
you know, we do things in life, whether they
are jobs or personal things that you just
hope will give you enjoyment, and you know,
enrichment in your life, and it certainly
gave me that.
I think that I'm still too close to it yet
to see what...
how it's changed me if it has changed me or
how it's informed me.
I think, maybe in 15 years I might know.
I mean genuinely though, very often you know,
things you learn in life, you don't know five
minutes later, you know them much later so
all I know is that I'm very, very glad I did
it, I'm very grateful that it was able to
work out and yeah...
I would have been without it in the last few
years of my life that's for sure"
M: "Thank you.
Lady in the front row here, we'll go there"
Audience Member: "Great film everyone; well
done"
MF: "Thank you"
Audience Member: "The question is for Lee
and Richard.
There's obviously a lot of male ego, love/hate
relationship over there.
Did it affect you on-set relationship in any
way?"
RA: "Male ego?"
Audience Member: "Yeah"
PJ: "There's a lot of male ego on this table"
RA: "It's kind of build into the relationship,
you know, you've got two kings that represent
two races and so it's essential there is this
standoff between two characters and it's setup
in the second film, and even thought the characters
don't really come face to face in the third
piece of the jigsaw puzzle you can really
feel the tension between the elves and the
dwarves, linchpinned by these two potential
kings, I think"
Audience Member: "Your on-set relationship?"
RA: "Yeah I mean we were pretty antagonist,
everytime the elf walked in to the room I
would bristle"
M: "Can we go... gentleman with the microphone,
there"
Audience Member: "Hi, this is Tiago from Brazil.
So this is hashtag #OneLastTime, I would like
to know from everybody, beside yourselves,
besides Middle Earth, besides working with
each other, what are you gonna miss the most?"
M: "Can you direct that to a couple of people
please, 'cause we've got a lot of questions
to get back to"
Audience Member: "Peter Jackson"
PJ: "I think you've answered the question
and the truth is, I'm gonna miss the fun on
the set, I mean, as Martin said, I kind of...
making films is very very hard and if you're
make three of them like this, 266 days of
shooting, it could be bloody hell if it's
not fun, so I kind of...
I wanna go to work in the morning and have
fun, I wanna enjoy myself and... fortunately
this cast is just such a fantastic cast and
they're all very, very funny people and I
just, you know... outside the fact that the
cameras were rolling and we were all doing
our part to create the movie, as soon as the
cameras stopped rolling we just...
I mean, it was just fun.
It was an enjoyable way to spend the day,
and I'm surely gonna miss that, that's...
yeah"
M: "Okay, if we can get a microphone down
the front row and then we do some question
over this side, and then we come back over
here in a sec"
Audience Member: "Peter, mainly, and Ian,
and everyone else on the panel that perhaps
has children, I wondered, with J.R.R.
Tolkien's writings, I'm sure most people in
the room would agree that the books are brilliant.
Do you think that there's still literature
written for children today, that's as good?"
PJ: "Do I think there's literature..."
Philippa: "Yes, absolutely.
Yes I think... and formed and influenced by
him, and we have... actually have a children's
book, well wonderful children's book, author
sitting at this table, Evangeline Lilly"
PJ: "Squickerwonkers"
Philippa: "Squickerwonkers.
Highly recommend it... who.... is venturing
into that?
The world of imagination so..."
PJ: "Yeah, yeah"
M: "Great thank you.
And if we can go to the gentleman with the
hat in the front row and along to the blue
coat"
Audience Member: "Hello there., I've got a
question from my ten year old son, Hag, it's
to whoever is brave enough to answer really.
There's now six movies, which one's your favorite?"
All: "uuuuh..."
EL: "Fellowship"
RA: "Two Towers"
IM: "Fellowship of the ring"
MF: "I think maybe, Two Towers"
Audience Member: "I think that enough.
Let's move on"
PJ: "I like the Battle of Helms Deep actually,
I mean I like the Two Towers but I like particularly
the Helms Deep sequence.
I....
I... yeah I mean... yeah"
Audience Member: "They're all brilliant"
MF: "Thank you"
M: "Can you pass the mike along please; we'll
do the lady and then the gentleman in the
blue coat, thank you"
Audience Member: "Can I ask Peter, given your
daytime immersion in fantasy what do you dream
about?"
PB: "Fran Walsh"
Audience Member: "Sorry?"
PJ: "Well I mean, I...
I uhm...
I...
It's a very boring answer, but every time
I make a movie and these movies were no exception.
The first day I start shooting, I start having
a recurring nightmare every single night that
I'm lying in bed and there's a film crew surrounding
the bed waiting for me, to tell them what
to do, and I don't quite know which movie
I'm actually making.
And I'm not sure, I don't think there's even
a script, and they're all standing there needing
to have information from me and I'm in bed,
I'm tired, I'm exhausted, I can barely think
straight, so I'm sort of... and that nightmare
starts on the clock the first day of shooting
and it's every night till the last day of
shooting, and then I... then I... then it
stops.
So it's hell 'cause I have all day on set,
then I go sleep and it's all bloody night
on set as well.
Uhm... so that's what I dream about.
It does stop, the day we stop shooting it
goes away, and then I have nice dreams"
M: "Gentleman in the blue coat please.
Thank you.
We'll come back to you"
Audience Member: "Uhm... congratulations guys"
All: "Thank you"
Audience Member: "It was a beautiful movie
and I can't wait to show my children.
And it's unprofessional of me
to say I had a little cry"
All: "Aaaawh"
Audience Member: "In terms of the films, particularly
the next generation seeing such powerful stories,
and this is obviously cinematically telling
Tolkien's story.
I'm thinking particularly Martin for yourself,
do you feel a sense of pride, that this is
essentially a story about the little man,
figuratively and literally, who's made a big
impact on the world, who has a message that's
important to pass on.
You usually play a guy who's like the everyman,
how did you find putting yourself in this
fantastical situation, because you weren't
in
the other ones, so it's also new for you
in your life as well?"
[Many thanks to Camilla Kristensen for generously
transcribing these subtitles.
Further subtitles for
the rest of
the video will follow.]